three years ago kyle shanahan signed a
six-year contract to be the head coach
of the san francisco 49ers now with
three years left
he's signed a new six-year contract
extending his stay three years beyond
the current deal he's basically where he
was when he started back in early 2017
as head coach of the 49ers
look that's not a surprise to me at all
kyle has done a great job in a short
period of time turning around a
franchise that was lost they went from
jim harbaugh to jim tomsula to chip
kelly it was a revolving door they have
stability now in their head coach
and i'm not surprised at all chris uh
what what what what's he gonna buy you
with his uh his newfound riches
well i mean i know i'm never paying for
dinner again that's all done with it's
the the tab is on kyle from here on out
but uh it is well deserved i mean this
is a guy that as you know mike and
you've been around kyle a little bit
he's very passionate about his job he
lives it he's been invested in it for a
long long time he's brought a new energy
to the 49ers organization to what you're
talking about even when they went 6 and
10 and 4 and 12 the first two years you
know it was a quarterback issue i think
everybody still saw that whoa this
offense is good and how many close games
did they lose and things like that
because of the lack of that quarterback
but they got jimmy garoppolo in a full
season and being healthy and everything
like that and i think it truly showed
you the potential of shanahan as the
head coach what his offense could be all
about and we don't even think jimmy
garoppolo is hitting on all cylinders
yet so uh i i'm really excited for kyle
and i think this is a wise move by the
san francisco 49ers
when the deal was first done it was both
kyle shanahan and john lynch with
six-year contracts
because the idea was to send the message
that we have stability again we are not
going to be throwing coaches and general
managers out the door on a regular basis
the jets have since copied that with joe
douglas the gm they hired after mike
mccagnan with a six-year contract there
was a twist in the shanahan deal and
also applied to lynch it was fully
guaranteed with no offset meaning
they're getting that money no matter
what even if they get fired and go
somewhere else so it creates an
incentive for the 49ers to keep them for
the full six years one thing we haven't
seen yet in the reporting as to the
shanahan deal and the announcement
doesn't address this either is this deal
also six years fully guaranteed with no
offset i don't know that they need that
this time around it's part of what you
negotiate and maybe if you're kyle you
take a little more money in lieu of
having that kind of security because
here's the thing if the 49ers fire him
in the next six years he's going to land
on his feet somewhere else given what
he's already accomplished and what he's
already accomplished there should be no
reason for the 49ers to want to fire him
at any point over the next six years no
i mean i i wouldn't think so i mean i
think this is the start of a new you
know an era in san francisco i think you
found a coach the to be a guy that could
be the face of your franchise for the
next 10 20 years you know that's the
kind of talent in mind i think kyle
shanahan has you know it's uh to me he's
one of those few guys mike and i know
listen i'm biased but i know a lot of
other coaches in football and you don't
hear me talk like this about them you
know kyle is cutting edge in all aspects
and bringing new ways to train to the
football team and new ways to study he's
cutting edge that way he's like a
belichick and he's never afraid to learn
more football but a new way to do it and
oh maybe i need to change or reinvent
myself and that's where i think he's
really special without a niche in the
nfl and him and you know i would expect
lynch gets an extension at some point
here soon too but uh just again i you
know i know he's my friend but he's one
of the smartest people i've ever been
around when it comes to football ever i
mean that's what kind of mind kyle has
here's the one thing i want you to find
out because
last season
resulted in this extension and last
season he wore that trucker skateboarder
had all year and his wife made him wear
it because it was good luck the fact
that it led to the extent i think he's
got to wear it all six years now oh i
think he's lost gotta wear it
he is he's locked in it's become like a
talking point between you know his
family his friends everybody so yes i
think that's part of like you know
his look overall he'll be wearing that
trucker hat for sure
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports